[Music]
go it's the rise of the Joker here's my
card
he's terrifying I thought my jokes were
bad it's pretty amazing to see an actor
you know come to set as himself as an
ordinary guy you know with the makeup on
and everything but as he and then just
get into character and create this
monster see I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the curve Heath just
immersed himself completely in it did a
superb job was very satisfying to work
opposite and you know the trivia thing
is is is that you know should Cris
decide to make a third movie how the
hell do we surpass what he's achieved
with the Joker but I see my face I do
feel like he loved his character he'd
love to act he loved doing this movie he
loved Chris and we all got such joy from
watching him do this I mean when I had
my time with heat in the movie I it was
in total awe of them you know I was just
watching him I was I'm in a kind of a
paralyzed state or whatever and I was
just watching him do his thing and just
kind of hanging on and doing my job and
admiring him at the same time because
it's all part of the plan being around
that business firing and fun anything I
throw at him I'll take it it's great it
was just great little fight you I like
that I think he's remarkable in the
movie I think he's doing something in
this movie that is extremely rare even
among the greatest actors I think it
happens only only every once in a while
I think you and I are destined to do
forever he gives a phenomenal
performance in this no one is more
deserving and and nothing to do with the
circumstances now and of course I wish
Heath was here talking about this as
well nothing to do with that you know if
he was if he was here he would still be
deserving of an award for this he's done
an incredible job
[Applause]
[Music]